delphine wespiser était avec nous ce
soir
delphine votre ami votre fiancée roger
les amener passé une nuit pour la saint
valentin dans un château complètement de
chauny à mon avis cette caméra cachée
elle va faire partie du top 3 joue de
vie des plus grands draps sera qu'un
chroniqueur et vécu c'est un véritable
film on est d'accord delphine là vous
allez regarder une fin film j'avais
regardé une fiction c'est un ya les
moyens de ouf
non bonsoir madame bonsoir monsieur
bonsoir
alors roger à la réservation we qui
mesure l a dit cet indice est la chambre
louise vous êtes déjà vu au château été
non plus que vous connaissez pas
l'histoire du château alors marquis de
montespan s'est installé ici à peu près
de 200 ans dans toute sa famille et la
marquise louise sa femme entretenait une
relation avec le palefrenier accord les
deux amants se sont débarrassés du
parent qui l'a jamais revu bah tant
qu'il n'est pas dans notre armoire je
pense pas non ne vous inquiétez pas
payer monsieur c'est l'accord s'applique
pas ici
[Musique]
énorme y en a c'est comme dans les
châteaux comme ça roger quoi tu aimes ce
truc je ne me sens pas bien je ne me
sens pas je suis pas de souci je ne le
sens pas bien je te dis je sors rejet
chez rim j'ai rien fait veut justement
ça promet
la mef regarde là me fait peur mais on y
regarde la meuf [ __ ] les yeux la meuf
et ta bouche là on garde le tableau on
dirait que c'est toi
bonsoir la réception votre table de près
et akwa au menu votre table est prête
jeudi il ya quoi au menu raccrocher
merci beaucoup
d'après match
[Musique]
où
ça va être compris viendra
[Musique]
je savais
j'ai jemma chien champagne gardien
arrête qui a les régimes qui vient de
passer et à regarder le ciel tu as par
les clients et le personnel requis qui
sont ces spas l'année en cours
jeanne ply qu'agir en les serrant reste
à leur merci je cherche des couleurs pas
peur vient d'en face
pour moi elle est ouverte la porte
[Musique]
au général
il
oh
[Musique]
enfin et moi autant chez rim ouvre toi
je vais commencer à pleurer géant fermé
je suis enfermé
on attend bouge pas
cheyrou
[Musique]
jerry qu'est ce que tu vois
attends bouge pas et chirac
non oui tu restes tu vois là bas ouvrez
moi cette banque et je la bouge pas je
m'enfonce et la faune
m
mais pas
[Musique]
ah ah
elle attend vous voyez pas votre voiture
qu en train de brouiller sur le parc
commence à ma voix duel en train de
pulls et chérie currie vaughan cite us
par mois
pied [ __ ] mais les pompiers passent
ici c'est rigolo
qu'est-ce qui se passe
[Musique]
à
par jean l'espoir excuse face au yen à
wade big lots vient aussi bien sombre
tous
j'arrive pas à ouvrir
chercher moi selector voix et loire
[Applaudissements]
padoue
[Musique]
oh
chéri c'est moi
elle a quoi ma voiture mais la cour
comprend rien
attends mouchoirs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
poussarou savais que tu viendrais la
maison tu as fait des misères n'ai pas
peur
[Applaudissements]
je comprends ce qui fait la voilà la
vraie peur en fait c'est un truc de fou
[Applaudissements]